you ever been hit by a real man or like
a daddy woman you ever been kidnapped or
played hide-and-go-seek rather poorly
you ever eaten candy and the pews at
church you sugar a little Hester Prynne
I was in Philadelphia all weekend I had
a sensual relapse I got my first guest
coming on a trouble brother that I met
at the DMV Oh welcome to this past week
this past weekend dented the turn to the
dot that a done don'tdon't that it's
done did it done that's a bad rendition
of the rocky song man welcome to this
past weekend I put that out there
because I was in Philadelphia but today
it's gonna be May it's May first man I
believe it's May 1st 2017 and I
appreciate you guys being here with me
man we got a lot going on we have a
guest coming in I got my first guest uh
this troubled gentleman that I met and I
say trouble but you know a man who's
going through things just like we all
are he and I kind of bonded at the DMV
it's a Department of Motor Vehicles it's
a great equalizer of humanity you know
everybody has to go there and in he and
I were both there at the same time and
he had an issue with a snicker bar I
think it was a snicker maybe a payday it
could have been a payday candy and he um
but he was making me laugh and and I
thought I would have him on man so he
not been communicating he's coming in
today Steven is a gentleman's name this
past weekend I was in Philadelphia the
City of Brotherly Love unless you're
over off of Godfrey and second Avenue
then a couple brothers over there were
not loving each other saw two gentlemen
one of them was look like a tire iron
from kind of far away they were I don't
say we're beating each other but
definitely tapping each other one of
them was tapping the other guy real hard
with a with a tire iron
and I don't know if you can I don't if
you cannot beat somebody with a tire
honor I don't know if you can just you
know casually hit hit somebody of the
tire and so it looked like a beating to
me but I had a good time in Philadelphia
I hadn't spent much time there I went to
an event called night at the fights and
Bernard Hopkins was there one of the
greatest welterweight champions I
believe of our time I believe it's
welterweight and this gentleman I saw
him one time outside of a fast-food
joint here in Los Angeles but uh
Philadelphia is his home city there and
he looked you know he looked very like
his face had been kind of I want to say
rearranged and I'm not shaming him I'm
just saying I've never seen a boxer up
close this much and he looked like like
a child had kind of made his face or
like an artistic child a are not a you
like an artistic child had kind of made
his face out of a paper mache or
something you know kind of you know from
one of those um you know like they put
it on a balloon member I used to do that
in in school you would do an arts and
crafts and I really I felt like I
excelled at arts and crafts personally
and that's you know that something I
felt like I did do well with glue and
all the craft materials but um but
anyhow it look like his face had been
like a child had made it on a balloon
you know you put the paper mache on then
you pop it and you're left with what you
created kind of a little sunken in
because the balloon is now gone it's not
supporting the paper mache and it looked
a little bit like that like like his
face had been just slightly kind of
renovated like it like his eye was like
you know like here and I there and I
everywhere a lip lip kind of like um
like old old McDonald I guess manna and
I realize I'm kind of breaking into that
cancer there but yeah kind of old
McDonald just you kinda
like you ever remember those things on
the wall that you had to get close to
and then slowly back away from and they
would it would form a picture and you
could see it it was like a it used to be
a it was a book or some other people
would have them framed on their walls or
something and and the image would appear
it was like a 3d image but not if you
were just looking it was kind of like
that a little bit with mr. Hopkins face
and again I'm not shaming him I'm just
letting you know you know what a
championship boxer looks like years
later and it kind of reminded me of that
a little bit like like if you got close
you were kind of like oh what is this
but if you kind of move back slowly then
you're like oh boom that's Bernard
Hopkins so it was interesting to be
there it was it was a charity event
where I was performing and they had some
singers called brotherly love there in
Philadelphia for young gentleman who
extremely talented and they had a lot of
great fights they had five sanctioned
boxing matches and they had four I
believe celebrity matches and I'd never
been to a boxing match you know I don't
know if you guys have been to boxing I'm
not I've never I've been beaten a few
times by people I I have a dream where
I've repeatedly punched this uh.this
Ranga this red-haired kid I repeatedly
punched him he works at a Popeye's
Chicken he's a manager and I have a
dream I repeatedly punch him so that's
kind of like a fight I guess I've kind
of won I don't know if he's even allowed
to punch me it's a dream of mine but um
and then I remember one of my friends
actually when I was in middle school we
weren't friends at the time but he was
the biggest guy in our school Bradley
was his name and uh and he and he and I
were you know facing he saw facing off
against each other and I knew it was
going to escalate and I was hoping it
didn't but I didn't want to look like a
wimp and all the kids were circled
around and somebody took I had my arms
by my side somebody took my fist and
pushed it into him and then he
beat me that man when he wasn't a man
but he was as much of a man as you could
see in the fourth or fifth grade he beat
me pretty decently but they had a
program at our school in middle school
this was at cj Shan middle school the
same school that Lee Harvey Oswald used
to attend so just add a little bit of
texture to the environment and at our
school if you got in a fight they had a
man named Lawton McKee and he was the
Prince of PAL not the principal that was
his motto I'm your principal and he
would make you a hug so you and the man
whoever you got to fight with your co
fighter or might your beater in this
point I mean I felt like a spouse and
this thing I felt like a 1970 spouse you
had to stand there in the hallway for
the rest of the day with your arms on
each other's shoulders and that let
everybody knows you were fighting it was
it kind of like you were shamed a little
bit it was almost like when they used to
put your head like in the guillotine or
whatever you know and they would make
you stay in the stocks or whatever all
day and like the 1600s or whatever or
something Robin Hood times but but
anyhow me and this guy Bradley had to
stand there and you basically have to
hug each other all day you have to keep
your hands on the other person's
shoulders and all the kids between
classes are running by and it's really
embarrassing but he and I became great
friends from that because you just it's
great you get connected you're standing
there you can't be enemies at a certain
point you know you're joking around or
you're you know you get past it so I
thought that was a pretty neat method
that they used in middle school and he
became a friend of mine but those are
some of the fights that I've been in
mostly light beatings or my mother beat
me a lot when I was a child what else
that was pretty much it but uh but it
was so it was cool to see some fights
man it was cool to see I mean just the
intensity of it I mean these guys are
like just like violent ballerinas the
footwork and they flew a lot of fighters
up from Mexico
and they had five fighters from
Philadelphia and they had three three of
them were facing Mexican fighters and
and it seemed like it were just to kind
of fluff their records a little bit you
know like they fly these guys up from
Mexico they probably pay them you know
maybe fifteen hundred or two grand for
flying up and I mean some of them took
some of them took some beatings it was
kind of sad a little bit I felt first of
all I felt like it might not even happen
anymore with the North American Free
Trade Agreement you know looming trouble
looming there but this might be the end
this might be the last time some of
these guys come up here and get beaten
and it might not always get beaten I
mean I hadn't been to fights before but
they seemed like sacrificial lambs sort
of to you know potentially Pat had the
records of these Philadelphia boxers and
it was wild to watch man I mean just
just the intensity of it it blew my mind
man it blew my mind and but some of the
boxers the Latino guys it was almost
like when the you you know when you put
a mouse when you feed a snake you know
and I never had a snake I live with a
boy that had a snake one time and it bit
him it kept biting him and then it I
think it choked to death on I'll say on
a gumball he was in the gumball business
he was slinging balls at local grocery
stores and outlets this is back when gum
was King this is 15 years ago you know
at least and he had a snake that I think
choked to death on and I think it was a
gumball honestly I don't I don't
remember too much more about it but and
ironically I think it was a ball python
and that's not a joke I think that it's
what it was but anyhow um and I remember
he would feed him these mice you know
put these Mouse's or yeah small mouse in
there small and he'd put him in there
and and it was I felt you know I just I
hated watching that man I hated watching
a snake get fed and I know it's the
chain of I know it's the food chain you
know it's like when I eat a chicken
you know if there's another chicken over
at the window looking in it probably you
know feels disappointed that this is how
it goes that I just buy it and thaw it
out and cook it I mean at least he at
least this mouse has had a chance in
there it was alive but it didn't really
have a chance against a snake and that's
how I felt with some of these Mexican
fighters you know they fly them up it's
a it's a real fight it's sanction so it
counts against their record in the
Philadelphia fighters records and some
of them did a great job there were a
couple guys I thought had a chance to
win one of the guys I almost thought was
going to beat the Philadelphia boxer but
it was aw but then it just reminded me
of that just that that snake just like
dang you know this mouse doesn't have a
chance and it's in there and it's
feeling its life out but it just looks
scared because I guess I've romanticized
it you know I guess I always
romanticized when I heard that that a
snake ate a mouse I guess I felt like a
mouse probably was somewhere and was
cold or maybe didn't have clothes and
then a snake like like a snake came
along and was like oh he you know hate
cold Mouse why don't you get inside of
my mouth it's warm in my mouth and then
a mouse just got in there and and then
it just swallowed it like trickery I
didn't think it was as violent as it is
when you see a mouse just fighting for
its life in a cage where a snake lives
in a snake's cage so that that's kind of
what uh what seemed like occurred to me
that's what was going on in my brain as
I watched some of these Mexican fighters
you know just fighting for their lives
out there against some of these
Philadelphia boxers some amazing boxers
man it's given been to a boxing match
it's good man I mean the closest I've
seen a boxing in a while was probably I
saw some UFC recently and then I saw
some Real Housewives of Atlanta a few
years back and those [ __ ] were
getting pretty legit on there some hand
action what else man sensual update I'll
hit you guys with that dude I'd been
doing pretty decent I'd strung
rather about seven days of laying off
the mass tea and not doing any self
gratification no jerky no no heavy
touching man some sometimes even if I
wanted to grab myself or in my pecker
area I would just instead just press my
palma gainst my penis hard just real
hard and kind of just you know vibe
there a little for a second but I
wouldn't do any you know actual you know
trying to pleasure myself I committed to
try and go 90 days without doing
masturbation and some of you guys I've
gotten calls from people on the hotline
and we're going to get some calls in a
little bit we're gonna have our first
guest in today I'll tell you about that
in just a second
but I've gotten calls people like would
would you who gets masturbation mine you
know welcome from from another country
you know what do you have against like
we can't drug off you know it's good for
you and I feel that man it is if you if
you don't have a issue if you haven't
you know if you don't have a bad habit
of it then yeah I'm not saying don't
masturbate I'm not saying don't touch
yourself or do pleasure okay or find
pleasure in your crops or do special
things with yourself but I'm saying to
people that have an issue that have
created a bad habit of it which in my
life it is when I look back on my life
it has been a bad habit its I've created
a bad habit where it's not
I don't just get pleasure out of it I
get some sense of shame out of it so
that's why I'm trying to correct that's
why I'm trying to correct myself I'm not
telling you if you don't do you know
spraying or self skeet and you don't
have an issue with it you're fine you
don't think it makes you you don't feel
any shame then that's fine I'm not
telling you to do this I'm just sharing
what I am doing okay so I just want that
to be known but yeah you know so so I
got to start over man I got to start
over I'm going for 90 days I have a
sponsor I know that sounds crazy I have
basically like a masturbation sponsor
where you check-in
let them know what's going on and that's
awkward
I may not you know that's awkward to
make that call and leave a voicemail to
a man and let them know that you've been
touching yourself you know when you're
in your 30s so so I'm not feeling super
bad because I'd you know I'd had a good
week there I didn't look at any
pornography I've done a good stretch off
of pornography and I think pornography
is the devil dude and you can think it's
not and that's fine if you were using it
comfortably but I got to a point where
it was a bad habit so for me that's
Satan's little puppets out there when I
see pornography so that's how I feel
like like it's ruining men okay it's
taken away some of our sensuality it's
killing Qi it's a Qi killer bro and it's
enough of that going on out in the
mainstream media they're trying to kill
men they don't want us here okay I
believe that they want strong lesbians I
feel like they'll probably have
underground labs where they're trying to
grow stag meat onto a lesbian and they
don't even need men anymore and I'll you
know and that's a very much a
possibility you know you drive by you
hear about these bunkers and stuff and I
don't even know if it's the military
anymore you know years ago as a military
doing weird [ __ ] you know like trying to
you know put baby's eyes into a grown
man we'd always hear that rumor or you
know different stuff like that you know
trying to switch people's legs and make
them dance and or you know different
stuff but now I think it's big business
you know it's probably Google down there
trying to you know you know not tie but
sew or knit a man's crotch on to a woman
or they're trying to get rid of us so by
us spraying out on the internet every
night and waking up all good good good
we're not helping our own cause men I
strongly believe that so anyhow onward
but that's what's going on with me I had
to do a sensual update and check in with
you guys let you know where I'm at I'm
feeling some remorse
I'm going to go for 90 days though and
we'll see we'll see what happens man
what else can I get into I saw that
President Trump didn't go to the
Correspondents Dinner which I thought
was hilarious he went to Harrisburg to
spend time with his fans what would you
do you're gonna try going over to like
it's like going to a bunch of chicks at
hey cheese house
guess what chicks not going to come over
there okay i'ma go hang out with a
couple of bad [ __ ] that I know enjoy
my company like I just get what he's
doing like you know like it just seemed
like such a beef
I thought half the jokes that they
played about him were gutter anyway were
muppet I mean it's kind of hard when the
only people that can be made fun of
anymore white people you know but I'm
not going to get political man I got I
got a guest coming in and I want to tell
you about him he'll be in in just a few
minutes first I want to tell you about
these dates this weekend May 6th and 7th
I'll be in Phoenix Arizona my mother
used to live there outside of Glendale
and she actually lives in Tucson now I
just remembered that she's seen a
gentleman as Alzheimer's and they're
doing stuff out there together what else
Tampa Florida Tampa Florida that's
pirate country a lot of dbn ex-husbands
and bad mustaches down there in Tampa
and that's made 25th to may 28th they'll
be there at side splitters June 1st
through 4th I'll be in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania
I caught pinkeye there one time um
Kordell Stewart allegedly got a blow job
there years ago in a sand trap on the
off Schenley Park golf course what else
I got a blow job there behind the giant
eagle which is just a Kroger they
renamed it I guess when you get up into
that region that's just a Kroger grocery
and June 23rd and 24th I'll be in New
York City at Gotham comedy club and
Gotham comedy club that's over there if
I think like 25th and 3rd 23rd and 5th
I'm excited about that and June 30th
being Wyoming Illinois that's near the
Quad Cities in Iowa it's about 40
minutes from Peoria Illinois it's my
mother's hometown and we're doing a
beautiful fundraiser there in that area
so you can come see so you can come and
check that out we're doing a beautiful
fundraiser there tickets are on sale on
Theo von comm slash tour for all of
those
it's the hempen ain't easy tour you can
still get the album online and I got a
guest guys I know I've talked about it
I'm nervous about it and I also want to
let you know I'm yeah I didn't even tell
you the backdrop today I just I just
felt comfortable man we're here at
conscious studios in in Santa Monica and
I met a gentleman basically we basically
met off the Internet's off the web's you
know and gentleman sure and he's uh he's
a producer he runs audio and and he
invited me to come in here and try to be
here in his in their studio tonight
conscious studios so I'm really you know
I feel fortunate about that because I
had no plan for this no plan you know I
mean I didn't have a big plan anyway you
know I mean I just have you know I just
feel grateful that this happened Here I
am I'm sitting in a beautiful studio
they had a dog here earlier beautiful
dog I don't know how old it was maybe a
middle aged or younger animal and Here I
am enjoying myself here and feeling
comfortable man I forgot to tell you
that I was here I'm sure you're like
where are you are you in like a Space
Lab no I'm here conscious studios I got
a guest coming in guys he's going to be
here in just a moment
a metal gentleman at the DMV and we
chatted briefly as gentleman Stephen and
he seemed kind of uneven to me you know
he seemed a little he seemed like he'd
been through a lot and we all go through
things in it but he had a lot of joy he
also had like a he was a little bit wild
in the
as I could tell that he'd been through
some of the ups and downs and I invited
him here tonight and he's coming I
didn't know if you would come but he's
going to be here momentarily so I'm
excited to kind of talk to him I don't
know kind of how it's going to go you
know but I but I am excited I'm excited
that he's coming
yeah man you could scoot over next to it
- you want me to see a little bit cooler
on him yep
yeah we're good man I think good luck
yeah man thank you so much ah so Steven
I met you at the DMV I'd imagined and uh
it was cool yeah it was cool man you
were chilling and you had your you know
arm
something's wrong with your leg at the
time I felt I had that boot on yeah not
a Buddha's off look healthier than
though you see it yes here oh you got
off a little bit I could stand up you
got both wheels man are you feeling
better
uh you know what I feel a lot better but
uh inside it's like hurting but I still
feel it though yeah it's like the pain
never leave you yeah when you get hurt
y'all never the parent never leave you
are you thinking stays in your body and
like if you get shot or whatever you
still gonna feel it yeah you know saying
yeah you know so what's been going on
with you man since I saw you um what's
it like man tell me about your life a
little bit my life is going on it's
going good yeah I'm trying to check
myself in a program or whatever I'm you
know I'm living downtown LA okay nice
man it's like Lord I'm scream the name
of the Lord I'm like man let me get
about it this situation on man yeah and
I don't want to be in the situation I'm
in so I got a say hey let me check
myself in the program or something yeah
I got 30-day program you know seven-day
cuz I'm in I'm in no months a long time
yeah y'all currently I 12 months don't
send this a long time yeah you know like
you said yeah I feel that man I just got
nine months oh brother - nine months
sober yeah that's a good thing so I just
got this the first time I've been into
uh into a program but I decided I'm on
yeah
so I'm I'm congratulations thank you man
I could knock and say that I appreciate
it yeah I mean
you know that's why I'm here yeah you
could teach me how to do it you know
well I'm not going to lie to you I mean
you set it on the way in just having you
know I have a toughest time trying to
control my own life instead of just
turning it over to a higher power
that's my toughest problem it is tough
for me too
yeah it is I want to control everything
but yeah yeah it's not that tough now
look not once you make like them demons
in you yet you go do you try to find the
demons on your own yeah
when so it's a higher power that can do
it for you do it for yardages and then
we're here you answer your own question
there you go there you go young man why
do we do that you think why do we
continually try to control everything
man what am i why do we have such a
tough time you think turning it over
because we still try to control on in
destiny we'd be like I want to do it for
myself I want to do this I can do it by
myself
yeah I'm spider-man I'm Superman and
whatever the character that you claim to
be yeah I'm here buddy never the counsel
of Grayskull whatever yeah Castle
Grayskull is nothing compared to the
Lord in front of God well father God you
know sin or whatever higher power
whatever he'll get that's what that
higher power I thought I can say you
know I feel you man so where are you
from Steve I'm from South Central I'm
from my life you grew up in South and I
grew up another sound sensor and what
was it like when you were growing up
here when I was a gangbang and I didn't
mean the gangbang but I would I'm a nerd
I went to school and my mom and Daddy
whupped my ass yeah I meant to go to
school yeah but it was like we had a
three-bedroom house in Long Beach yeah
so it wasn't no problem we got fed we
got our ass whooped
when it was need to be but two things my
mother dead man there's a lot of Elvis
yeah you know a lot of Elvis he made
decent macaroni my mother did yeah
my mama was making them so I know she
made a
what was that the the where we're beaten
right yeah and then she made a damn it
was in sardines sardines Hardy I didn't
eat that no one else to though it was a
salmon salmon pack oh yeah it was a
telling Patties but they're often Dean's
man under Dean man I didn't sell my
patties oh yeah you ever ate salmon
patties uh-uh
but you know what I had an ex-girlfriend
and her [ __ ] mother used to make them
all the time so I need them but people
like them the salmon pad yeah people
like them salmon patties family hey they
cook them like a little it's like a
burger yeah they can put them with they
do Lay's potato chips with them yeah
this beautiful snack it is this
beautiful snack it is is that I say that
was your sandwich a choice these days
you think my sandwich the source is I uh
I do a turkey sandwich yeah me kiddo
Turkey would uh like you give me some
Swiss cheese Swiss cheese Turkey yeah
and then I could do some Bologna with it
I am took the envelope I could do it
like that why I know everybody you know
yeah no harm no foul I never had that
man you go turkey Bologna I don't know
what they call it salami
yeah damn don't like sometimes I do it
huh yeah come when you smoke crack you
know you coming off that crack I ain't
smoked crack for two years
oh wow congratulations man no I'm saying
yes [ __ ] cried for two years
yeah meth I don't know yeah feels like
it's hard to control is it really it is
meth is hard to you know it's hard to
get off that man I never had trouble
with that man if a terminal cocaine but
never had any problems with a man was
never huh I just how did that happen I
feel funny because that you know I
didn't get involved with the drug with
drugs too much you know I just got I
started to have some problems with it
and that's when I started to leave it
alone
yeah I got into it through trying to be
hard I'm going to be a man yeah I wanted
to be a man you know and it's hard to be
a man out here without a kid you know
you got to be frickin
you gotta figure out your way on life
and it's like that
I don't know figure out one more in life
without a kid I gotta be a man I don't
have a kid do you have any children I
don't have a children I don't have a
child now yeah not that I know about
yeah it's hard to figure that one out
right now when I'm 41 years old and it's
hard to figure it out now so and what do
you when you were when you were younger
what did you want to be when you were
younger when I was young I wanted to
just be just like my dad is just a work
and just bring home bread yeah just feed
my kids and be like my daddy my daddy I
got three sisters and a brother yeah Oh
y'all had five times I through yeah I
got three sisters and a brother and they
all live in Los Angeles father yeah they
all like South Central Los Angeles but
it's like oh that's all I wanted to be
like my daddy I just wanted to have kids
and just take care of them and just work
and come home and sleep and you know say
it yeah whoop day but when they needed
to be whoop you know like ya'll said
just be like my daddy like you know
saying that's how my daddy was do you
think you'll still have a chance to uh
to be a father in your life do yeah I
mean you know I don't never leave that
out I'll never leave that out mom I
never leave that out I never leave it
out yeah I never leave myself out to
count like you know saying I could leave
myself out but I I never leave myself
out yeah because my my daddy told me
that he said man never leave yourself
out I always count yourself in yeah
never leave yourself out always count
yourself in you know then you never know
when you can win yeah you know just like
the lottery or whatever I used to crash
your ticket I see a lot of people
scratching tickets nowaday huh yeah now
yeah yeah and it's like you never know
where you can lose on me or win you know
but yeah you're survivor man it seems
like you have to be which if you don't
mind chairman like what's like a day in
your life like these days you know and
my day in the life is like just going to
go Panhandle and go get some change and
then make about 10 20 bucks you know
I'm trying to get some weed and and I
said I you know don't bother nobody
yeah if I bother somebody saying I know
I'm your father or whatever it seem like
I'm you know I don't know I don't want
to be no better than nobody like you
know it's not I gotta be humble
yeah I'm being humble not that it's like
I don't want to be in nobody's way I'm
not like like one of them little flies
like a butterfly yeah I don't want to be
in nobody's white and I hate it you just
want to stop and go stop and go yeah
just like that you know just hang you
see me now you don't see me but then
when you see me it's like it's a good
thing every time you see me it's a good
thing yeah nothing bad yeah so it seem
like your life's probably had ups and
downs in it do you blame anybody for the
things in your life
I don't tell times as I go through
moments where I blame I feel like I go
through moments mostly where I blame
myself don't blame nobody blunt blame me
I do I blame myself
I can't blame nobody else like just like
you said I don't blame nobody else yeah
I can't find nobody else to blame they
don't say when you go searching to
things and stuff like that you go
digging and stuff like that yeah how did
I end up in the place where I'm at yeah
I never blame nobody yeah nobody's to
blame have you battled addiction for a
long time I have yeah I'm 41 years old
right I looked at 41 man I mean I've
been battling with this little addiction
for a long time but now it's like I'm
just it's a long time battling just hope
I don't yeah yeah you know you just get
to it you know and it's like you look at
yourself in the mirror every day and be
like this is me yeah I have to do it
yeah go out and do it you know and it's
hard to get easy to it you find it's
hard to keep your hopes up sometimes
sometimes I find it's hard to keep my
hope so sometimes you just can't do it
though you can't you know just like you
say you blame yourself so when you blame
yourself
it ain't hard to do it you just go to
your gonna do your telling you don't go
to your life yeah you're diction's
that's your addiction not nobody else's
right it ain't nobody else's problem but
yours
yeah you know that's how I live my life
I mean you know I don't live my life
blaming nobody else you know saying hey
yeah yeah do you feel like you could
have done something different that would
have put you in a better place so far I
believe it I'll go I believe in it I
believe that I look back on my life and
I know there's some choices I could have
made like I'm grateful for where I am
you know because I'm grateful I'm still
alive I'm grateful I wake up every day
with an opportunity to make my life
better or to try and at least try and be
a better person but is there anything
specific that you look back on and
regret yeah I do a lot of things I kind
of did dope and I mean you know I didn't
when you do that dope you do meth
I didn't did you know when I went with
men I did all that stupid silly telling
oh yeah that happened on Friday and did
all this silly talk that happened with
drugs I didn't LDL it should be that's
not us nothing and I'm a man I mean I'm
a man I mean I'm a child of God
yeah I don't saying I'm not a you know
but uh but that's like I don't blame
nobody for the do would they do would
you do that drug yeah I don't blame
nobody from what they do yeah y'all
can't blame nobody but no if you do it
when you sober I can blame me then you
like you already a little yeah if you do
it when you're sober yeah but uh so you
know what were your dreams like when you
were young I mean I'm one of the beer
you know what I wanted to be just like
my daddy like yeah this is fixed
computers like I'm good at electronics
I'm good at doing that fixing things
yeah I always fix things
yeah my mom and my daddy they I mean my
mom always told me like I can fix this
I said you were too sick every
everything I'm the fixer yes you know
and what are your dreams like now really
likely now and now it's still the same
thing I mean it never change so it's
just like the same thing but it's it
like when you drink a lot and when you
smoke a lot and we
you put things in your life and you put
things in your system yeah in China the
whole situation on you know your whole
idea is tanjo the only know that you
were addicted at first or do you just
think you were having a good time I
never knew that until I went to a
program
yeah they teach you that when you when
you go to a program they teach you that
yeah hey listen you net but I don't let
them learn me you know I learned myself
to do you know I read the Bible a lot
yeah I go to God a lot yes and can't
nothing stop you when you go to him
that's it nothing stopped you when you
go to him do you see like do you feel
like your life can continue to get
better or you feel like is it coming to
get from where you are in your life to a
better spot like I'm really curious like
what is it like it can get better but uh
in my mind it seem like oh I can't go
nowhere
because when people it seems like I let
people judge me but I should not let
that I should not let nobody judgment
you were yeah you can service hold
everything I love me too man
my mind is like that light and I
shouldn't let that but I let that
overcome me sometime like yeah you know
say I think people think it on their own
yeah they don't want me around yeah I'll
be like like them you could you know
send a look looking at people like Navin
at me or whatever I mean I'm there
people like you know saying you're like
sometimes if I hear somebody laugh are
away they might be having a good time
they might not even know me know me but
I believe their lifetime here whatever I
think the last yeah and I think that and
I shouldn't let that overcome you know I
let those things overcome and I
shouldn't do that but uh you know it
works yourself out them that's what I
then then that's what the liquor come in
yes when I get to drinking yes you wanna
you want to knock kill that bad feeling
that pain yeah
Stephen man be even Stephen even Stephen
uneven Stephen what do they call you uh
Viet us even huh hey there you go yeah I
like what you said even
Thank You Man I like your attitude your
good what so what advice would you give
to young people or to anybody man that's
out there that struggling with the
diction man is really struggling I give
them you know what just you know what if
you don't do it do it do it run your
mama and do it a run your daddy do it at
home when you do it do it I don't do it
with your family don't do it with no
strangers yeah you know when you get
high do it with some people that you
know yeah don't do it around no
strangers I don't know you you know
that's all I could say to the youngsters
yeah if you're gonna do it do it around
some people that you love like some
loved ones yeah don't do it around no
strangers that don't care about you like
at least be smart about it be smart
about it
yeah I get hurt you know well Steven I
proceed coming and hanging out dude
would you come back again sometime I
don't know I mean let me know what's
going on I will and let us know you know
I will as I appreciate it man you know I
I mean I can't identify with some things
you said but I can identify with I can
identify with just wanting to make your
parents proud I'll do and not giving up
on that dream I do
exactly thank you long yeah cool man
Steven we appreciate you your chat
medicine we'll do it again soon we will
yeah all right man be good out there and
be in touch huh Thank You lot yeah thank
you
I'm going to get back I'll be back in
just a second I'm going to I'm going to
walk Steven out but I'm going to and
I'll catch some calls and uh and we'll
get on with a hotline we had a lot of
great calls that came in on the hotline
a lot of people talk about worries about
the future people don't believe in the
future you scared to the future Steve no
I mean I believe in future you heard
that's all you got if you don't have a
future we believe when what's behind you
you heard a man well I didn't want to go
behind you just go go forward yeah all
right I'll be right back is Steven we
back in a few weeks man thanks Steven I
appreciate it actually a lot yeah
always going to come back huh always go
forward all right man go forward and
just turn a couple times and make it
back here you know
you know here Jamie god bless you all
right guys we said Steven in here even
steven and I'm excited that he's going
to come back you know I don't know if
it'll be a regular thing that he checks
in with us or that he you know I don't
know you know he was it he was
definitely in a different vibe than then
he was at the DMV he was you know I
don't only know kind of what level he
was on he kind of seemed to calm down
after a bit you know but I thought it
was interesting for him to come in and
just share you know when to share some
of his story you know there's a first
interview that I've had with somebody in
here so I was you know a little pensive
you know I don't know him
so that was you know that can be an
issue sometimes if you don't know
somebody I but I did feel I felt
grateful that he shared some real stuff
from his life you know because all we
are I feel like is a lot of what we are
are some of the toughest things that
have happened to us and most of what we
do is not talk about those things and
that's one thing it's just kind of
fascinating to me about life and I think
it's one reason one reason why I
gravitate towards comedy because a lot
of times people on that stage are used
to seem like and some guys still are are
sharing you know things that they've
gone through real stuff and trying to
make it entertaining and that's one
reason why I like a lot of times going
to some of these different types of you
know meetings the AAA programs and the
sex sexual and love addiction Anonymous
meetings because you get to hear stories
in there like I can I can even talk to
some of my best friends
and it's hard to get to a real level
with them sometimes but man you go into
some of these rooms and you get to hear
people's realness you get to hear their
truth and you get to hear it a lot of
times without much filter and that's one
of the things that really draws me I
think to that environment it's one of
the reasons sometimes it may be bizarre
but it might be one of the reasons why I
stay sober because the only thing that I
have to give up my ticket to the show my
ticket to the a a show to be able to
hear people's stories and to be able to
just hear what they're in bro what
they've been through the dirt the dirt
in their heart it's just that I have to
give up I don't I can't drink or use
drugs that's the ticket
like hey you pay your admission today
yes I did then you can come in that's it
so anyway I don't know if that's why I
saying but but anyway back to it back to
Stephen it was interesting I thought he
shared a lot and it you know he has he
battles addiction I didn't realize that
as much I guess I thought that he you
know he'd been caught up in moments in
the dark arts but he definitely seemed
like like you know he had a boot on when
I met him but he was more jovial you
know like I said he was involved with
some Snickers or um it could have been
pay days or wops that what you McCall it
keeps popping into my head it's also a
candy a candy with a long name but it
pops into my head is that could have
been also something he'd been snacking
on but but anyway I'm glad that he came
in man and let's get to uh let's get to
some questions man you guys had some
calling questions and I'm going to look
for other four other guests to come in
you know you know I wanted to kind of
get into the life of a little bit of a
troubled brother I don't really sit down
that much and talk with a troubled
brother like like Stephen you know and
get to hear some of their problems so
for me
that was interesting you know and just
to sit there man-to-man and try to share
I was a little nervous to be honest with
you so hopefully if Stephen comes back
that we'll get to learn learn a little
bit more about him
alright let's get into some questions
here man now last week I wanted people
to call in about technology some
technology fears so let's start right
there
what's up Theo this is err from Kentucky
who hardly enjoyed the podcast Haley no
it's just great to hear B so from
somebody so uh open and honest about
their experiences thank you very much
Aaron onward um I wanted to just address
some of the concerns you expressed on
the last podcast about you know the
future of technology and stuff you know
I kind of felt like you all back up
pretty uh freaked out by the movie in
Corrections things we're going
especially with self-driving cars like
you expressed the fact of the matter is
man it's I am I didn't last week I
expressed some concerns about technology
like at what point is it not good for us
anymore you know like we're people like
at some point like if what if an enemy
came in and just kept attacking us so
that we couldn't use our brains and then
we didn't use our legs and then we like
we would if any in any other facet
that's considered a disease you know
like if somebody it's considered an
infection but just because it's
technology it's considered advancement
and that's where some of my hang-up is
I'm not anti-technology I'm
communicating to you guys right now over
technology we're we're interacting with
each other over technology but I am
worried I am worried anyway let's
continue on with uh with his question
here Aaron technology's just going to
keep proceeding and getting better and
better and hopefully help help our lives
anyways um back to the self-driving cars
I mean millions of people die every year
from car accidents like millions of
people I don't I have a tough time
believing that I would have served look
that up for us but I don't we'll have
any interactive capabilities here yet
I don't think millions of people die
every year from car
accidents I could have I could imagine a
million but I would I would be tough to
think that millions just because a lot
of people have cars but anyway onward
three or four accidents from the
self-driving cars so I mean that's
terrible you know that those people pass
away do you think about the live safe
from that no it's just amazing you know
that's just one example but yeah let me
say I'm gonna say this I'm going to
interrupt you there Aaron I'm going to
say this about the self-driving car I
think it's [ __ ] I'm not saying it's
not capable I don't think we're going to
get there I don't think in my lifetime
we will now in my children's lifetime
which I don't even have any children so
in someone's lifetime potentially if I
meet a woman that we're going to have
children yes then yes I think it could
happen then but they couldn't even make
a skateboard there was I don't know how
old you are but there was a rumor when I
was young they had the movie Back to the
Future one two or three came out and
they had a skateboard that skated for
you you'd have to do anything was
air-powered you know that that's never
happened okay maybe there's a video of
it happening someone they freaking they
had the ship thing that Justin Bieber
the single roller skate that he was on
and that thing was a piece of [ __ ] Mike
Tyson almost killed himself on one of
them and somebody else almost burned
down an airplane on one you know they
can't even make that that's just that's
just a [ __ ] electric roller skate so
you know this everybody's talking about
the self-driving car I don't see it I
don't see it because we could have it
now you know and we don't have it we
don't have the self-driving car you know
like we can't even get to we can't even
get to the to the to the to the
skateboard we were promised so I just
don't really see us getting that level
of actually having a thing of all the
infrastructure that have to be adjusted
and created okay so you have a
self-driving car but then you have
somebody that still wants to use a gas
powered car how is that going to work I
just don't see it working
I don't I honestly I don't see it coming
to fruition in my lifetime I'm not
saying that I'm against I just don't see
you coming to fruition anyway on I guess
the idea I want to express was that
technology is just the type of Sciences
propelling us forward right now you know
we've always had industry and medics in
different parts of times that have
progressed you know exponentially
exponentially fast and currently the
technology is just kind of pulling us in
that direction
it's a good point that's a good point
sometimes I think of it as you know that
it's never going to end but I guess
we're just at a time when it seems to be
the hot thing like the industrial
revolution occurred and at the time
people were like steel is it can you
believe steel you know and now which
it's just tech it's tech it's tech so
yeah and so if we can figure out how to
use it right and just not waste of all
of our time on a you know stupid apps
and stuff like that and you know give
back to the people that do end up losing
the jobs from stuff like self-driving
cars you know hopefully some kind of
universal income or something like that
and I'll stop you right there and I
appreciate your call Aaron I appreciate
you calling I appreciate you addressing
what was a concern of mine you know you
take it upon yourself to recognize that
that was something I was concerned with
yeah like that's another thing like yes
technology sure okay advancement robots
robotics where it takes away people's
jobs now that's alarming because then
you have you just have a man who
suddenly it feels useless and that's one
of the biggest concerns for me is I just
want to feel useless as a human being
like at some point it would be great to
just make it so we all have jobs I don't
need a [ __ ] robot doing something
there's I don't get anything out of that
you know like I'm the oldest I'm
old-fashioned you know like I want I'm
at a I've talked we're at a good place
now we're at a good place now we can do
all kinds of amazing stuff you know I
would love to see medicine advance more
but when it comes to the part where
we're taking away people's jobs I just
don't see the value in it you know and
my buddy that is like well everybody's
gonna drive uber but what everybody's
you can have uber drivers just pulling
guns on each other saying get him you
know trying to get passengers it's going
to be like two rubra drivers pulling
guns then I get in my [ __ ] car no
good a [ __ ] car to try and make
money um I just don't see the endgame
you know I don't see how it ends well
for humans because worse were the ones
that are living like why take away the
some of the joys are going to work
feeling useful especially for men like I
feel like a lot of Technology just takes
is just killing the spirit of men you
know they got these robot dicks out
there and I mean I know they've always
had you know dildos and electric you
know clitoral you know wands but now now
they have I saw something the other day
it's uh it hooks onto the wall and it
has like a crank or something and it
just [ __ ] whoever wants it you know I
what is it like I just don't see the
value at a certain point I don't feel
the value you know I mean how far do we
go you know I mean if you want to make
something that's going to help people
make something that's fun I can see that
you know make mittens that that put
themselves on you how about that huh or
like a shirt that climbs up your body
when you get up in the morning and puts
itself on you that'd be cool snaps all
go together you know what about or if
you could train your dick make something
that can you know communicate with skin
cells and it could train your dick to
come out of your pants and urinate and
then go back into your pants so you
could still you know look at your phone
or
while you're at the uh well you're at
the urinal you know what about making
our hair harder how about that I'd love
to see athletes that don't have to wear
helmets you know stupid helmets you
can't even see a lot of the athletes
facial expressions so how about that how
about making something that makes our
hair harder so that football players can
play football and just wear their hair
you know grow their eyebrows out or grow
out a beard to really get the full
helmet feeling you know I don't know
make our dicks harder what about that
make our dicks way harder so they can so
people quit fight with their dicks if
they needed to or you know get into
something open up a you know a door you
got locked out get in there or sharpen
your I don't [ __ ] know dude but those
are some things we're technology I see
the value you know in other ways I don't
see the value because at a certain point
by advancing technology we're making
ourselves as humans feel useless and
that is the line where I don't see the
value but to go back to Aaron the
caller's point or the colors inquiry and
you know some of us overall thoughts we
would need to have some sort of
compensation like if you know if there's
if a technology comes along that takes
away truckers the the the jobs of
truckers
then you need to subsidy need to give
something to those truckers so that
there is compensation there or create a
tertiary job that okay is safer so it be
less accidents less falling asleep at
the wheel
I mean truckers are doing gnarly [ __ ]
out there anyway I mean we let's be
honest about that I saw a man one time
had a damn chess board set up on his
trucker on his dashboard up there this
dudes doing chess okay a British game
doing British games and you know and
that was alarming because first of all
how the [ __ ] is a trucker playing chess
to be honest with you no offense if
you're a trucker but truck they're more
checkers guys
checkers type of men and to think this
man was doing that and operating this
big rig was alarming but uh but anyhow
yes if we're going to advance them we
need to have some sort of system in
place that subsidizes these people that
lose their jobs and create some sort of
a tertiary work environment where they
can still feel contributing and useful
because when a man doesn't feel useful
that's when the man can really get into
some deviant activities and can get
caught up in the dark arts and that's
true right there all right let's move on
to let's move on to another question
here let me see what we got we got um
[Music]
let me see
thank you my name is Josh I'm 24 Patti
we got Josh 24 from Cincinnati that's
chili country they have chili there
they're famous for chili and one I
haven't had two types of chili they're
popular one of them is disgusting I've
had that one onward just to start I
wanna say that uh listen to a few
podcasts and yours is by far the most
right now that I look forward to
okay that's good buddy let's uh okay
that's good let's go and anyway I'm
commenting because for quite a few years
now I've been interested in same County
and for about the last year over here
I've written some dates okay this is
Josh she's interested in stand-up comedy
and he has written some bits that's
where we are when were josh um and
playing to go up on stage but just has
never done up so I'm hoping maybe you
can be my tipping point can maybe um I
just think I'll have a good time with
and all enjoyed okay I'm going to
interrupt you there Josh I appreciate
your calling man it seems like you want
to know if you should do stand-up comedy
you've been thinking about it and I've
gotten a couple calls about this and for
one I'm going to let you know even just
from that call you get a half - you got
to project a little bit better or at
least speak clearer
I mean if you were calling from you know
a can it sound like you've been calling
one of those cans the children plug in
through a you know a piece of yarn to
another can I don't know what you were
calling from and I'm sorry to be mean
but I mean if you're going to call
trying and communicate you know we're
trying to communicate here that's the
number one thing we're doing and I need
you to do that if you call in but here's
the thing Josh I mean it sounds like
there's two reasons I think why you
wouldn't do it either you're lazy and
I'm not accusing you but I'm saying that
that's one of the things and I say that
because I've been lazy I can relate
you know there's things there's not a
week that goes by that I ask myself why
I haven't published a book you know I've
thought about doing that for years I've
written tons but can't get it together I
get lazy or I get caught up in my own
depression and also lazy alright I just
don't get it together but if you're lazy
man you got it you know
do something get up get going you're
young I think you say you're 23 or
something joined the army dude data
black man do something that's going to
get you you know on your toes even if
you're straight get out there and data
brother you know data black man that
will [ __ ] probably keep you on your
toes dude you know because being lazy is
an infection that's one thing that I
find in my life it's an infection man
and you have to battle against it you
have to battle against it whether it
means just setting an alarm and getting
up you know you do something for three
days in the morning you'll start to
slowly develop a pattern that's what I
find for me but the other reason you
haven't done it is that um that you're
scared the lazy thing I can't really
help you with you
that's a personal battle I feel like but
if you're scared that's something that I
feel like I can help you with and I'm
happy to you reached out about that you
know I'll say this doing stand-up it's
easier than you think
you're obviously already considering it
you know you're calling about it you're
curious you just have to get up there
and here are a couple of cheats that I
would use dude for one if you're going
to try stand-up comedy here's a couple
ideas tell a story tell a story that you
already know in your life that way it's
less pressure than a joke a joke you're
like you tell it and you're waiting for
that reaction a story you tell a story
and there could be moments along over
they laugh or moments long over they
just listen as long as you get to the
end of the story then you have at least
served a purpose you know you've at
least told a story and they've at least
heard a story so there's some exchange
there and then you can go back and
listen if you record you're set to
moments where if they did laugh and you
can start to mine those moments and add
more jokes in there or expound more in
those moments and then the next time you
tell it you'll have a little bit of a
different story or a bigger story and
you'll have a couple of places there
where you know laughter can occur and
just keep repeating that another option
tell some jokes in aren't yours we live
in a day and age where if it doesn't
even seem to matter if you tell jokes
that aren't yours anymore plagiarism
seems to be okay as long as you are you
know already popular you know so you can
always just tell some jokes that aren't
yours and do that I mean you could do a
me I mean Amy Schumer always gets
accused of it and she's a friend of mine
but you could it would be funny almost a
do Amy Schumer set get up on stage and
just try it or it'd be funny right
trying me Schumer set just try it or get
on stage and try any comedian set just
because
you're obviously just practicing you're
trying to get a feel for a stage so a
great cheat and a great and I don't mean
like I just mean in like a way like you
know to learn a great way to learn is to
take jokes that already work and just
say then you're practicing in front of a
crowd you're doing stand-up comedy
you're trying stand-up comedy you know
and I just use Amy Schumer because she
gets accused a lot Carlos Mencia is
always accused who I don't know who else
has been recently accused Oh Melania
Trump that seemed kind of plagiarized
but then all you know I feel like most
of the most of every presidential speech
of most of its also has sound the same
to me throughout my lifetime a bunch of
racket anyhow man if that's it those are
some options that can help you to maybe
try stand-up comedy all right onward
I appreciate it let's get into something
else here man let's get into another
call here you go
what's going on you little Gemini jester
this is John Doe calling from a
undisclosed location due to the subject
matter of what I want to call you about
but know this ought to be good John Doe
calling from an undisclosed location on
word Jonathan to yell all right I got a
good idea I'll keep myself accountable
so basically I've been struggling with
painkiller and heroin addiction for love
who sounds like a head sound like you
had one calling this throat right there
huh onward Spears now I'm 23 years old
and I'm really just sipping I do quite
well I'm making like you know two three
weeks at a time and end up using the day
and then I'll make it another two three
week so it's just it's never-ending
cycle because it sounds like let me use
the word cycle right there it sounds
like a cycle you know and that is the
that's the point whenever I was partying
that I noticed for me it wasn't healthy
you know and I'm going again to the
statement that look if you're out there
partying I'm not telling you not to
party I don't care if you're [ __ ] you
know you got two hookers at the bottom
of a wishing well right now and y'all
are doing you know you know little
eight-ball bumps off of each other's
bungholes you know that's fine that's
activity but what I'm saying is if you
are creating a bad habit or a bad cycle
then that's when for me I got nervous
let's keep listening to John Doe here
and his uh his deal it sounds like he
wants to make to keep them accountable
though because I've never really gotten
bad enough that I need to like help my
family and everybody so no one knows so
it's all like secretive and I can't
really tell anybody you like hey you
know try to keep me accountable if I do
screw up no and even it so I'm thinking
I want to start calling you every week
I'll call you every week every Sunday
night and I'll leave you a message
about how I'm doing I think that uh it
could be beneficial for me because I
really look up to you as a well I mean I
heard him say he looks up to me and I
appreciate that Steve ah sorry I almost
called him Steven dude which is
interesting because this is kind of like
a little bit how you know the
conversation ended with Steven you know
I wanted him to come back in you know I
want him to be well and then here is
this gentleman John Doe saying that he's
had a bad cycle that he's noticed in his
own life I'm saying this John if you
notice you know you're saying to me
you're 23 for three years you've been on
and off using it sounds like opiates and
pain pills to me I mean you mentioned
heroin but I don't see how you would
survive so well doing here but I've
never been involved with heroin but you
don't tell your friends you're not
asking them to keep you accountable
because nobody knows or your family but
you are reaching out to a stranger
which I appreciate man I appreciate you
reaching out there's a safe place to
reach out for sure you know it's why I
mean as weird as it is that this is out
in the world I consider it a safe place
to reach out to people you know to share
because I get some neat interaction but
people call in and I've got a lot of
great voicemails from people just being
encouraging and sharing advice at me but
I tend to get looking for something to
keep you accountable and what that's
called really is a sponsor man you know
it's a sponsor and you get that by going
into like an AAA or some type of a
program you know a sponsor will keep you
accountable so onward because a person
and I really appreciate the advice you
get and I think that it you know I know
that there's one up there who's going to
care that I did you know make it another
week and I did the right I think that
that could really help me talk to you
next week so far this coming weekend
okay I kind of trailed off maybe
hopefully didn't catch a bad gram there
at the end but I'll say this bro it
sounds like you need something you might
need a sponsor if you're starting to
worry about accountability you know and
that could be a real thing I'm happy for
you to call you know if it's you know I
you know I'd love for you to call and
leave us a voicemail I can't promise
that I'm gonna put it on the air I'm
gonna put make it a part of this past
weekend I can promise you that I'll
listen you know I can promise you that I
can promise you that I care that I want
you to get better but I also you know I
can't be I can't be a real sponsor I
could sponsor you but I can't be a real
sponsor like this you know in this type
of engagement but yeah if you want to
call in man John Doe from an undisclosed
location and let us know you're doing
from time to time if you can be candid
and realistic about what's going on and
share stuff that's real you know I'll
try and keep some of our listeners
updated if it fits man if it feels real
but I wish you the best of luck man and
if
you start to really get worried even
more than I'd look in maybe an AAA or
some type of a program let's get to
let's get to another question now I want
to say this I want to hear let's get to
one more really quick what's up yeah I
mean I was really super impressed with
your vocabulary you seem to just pull
these is extremely you know I don't
left-field words are you talking all the
time and it just impresses me do you
read books where do you get this extreme
vocabulary facebooking love it
you know I always liked words man I was
like words and sounds and I appreciate
you saying that though that I have a
nice vocabulary I actually want to go
back to school some time to really get
into writing in words and a friend um on
that diet he choked to death he was on
opiates and he choked to death on a
piece of chicken over there and
Woodville Mississippi but he got me a
rhyming dictionary when I used to work
on his farm and I really always
treasured that book and always like
sounds and I don't really I don't know
my brain just kind of surprises me
sometimes it words and I like words and
and I appreciate you at least you know
thinking that I had some sort of a flair
for um for the oral vernacular brother
all right let's get to one more call
here now I had a lot of people calling
about missing persons I had some good
ones and what I want to do this week I'm
going to try to I know I've said things
before I'm trying to do them we're
coming along when you you know an
amazing new spot this week by the grace
of a higher power and by sure being by
conscious studios over here in Santa
Monica I want to I want to get into this
missing persons thing more because I
told you guys that a boy when I was
young was playing hide-and-go-seek and
then he went in head and then he might
have just went off and hid away from
everybody forever we had some people
calling a good deal calls about missing
persons and so I want to I want to get
to one of them and then we'll try and
get to the rest of them maybe in a
tertiary
segment later on this week we'll put out
a little bit of a surprise episode of
much how to do it because I had a couple
of calls about them and I really wanted
to talk more about the missing and if
you are also a missing person or if you
have been or dated someone that's
missing or knew somebody and you can't
find them you can call about that and
leave that on the hotline I'll give that
hotline number one more time right here
that number is nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three also if you
are missing if you are someone that's
missing you can call if you want to
leave a message to your loved ones and
just let them know that you're okay and
we'll try to put that on on the show as
well we're going to get to one of them
right here though right now here we go
this is hey Pierre Lana so this week you
asked listeners to call in about a
missing person and that's ironic because
I'm about to become a missing person so
to provide you with some context please
do brother just got threatening to
become a missing person pretty much so
I'm the son of like to immigrant parents
okay son of a couple of grunt quality
that runs rampant among immigrant
parents is narcissism and a bit of a
controlling behavior and they really cut
it and that's pretty true I think my
friend Fahim is a you might be a set
first second or first generation I don't
know what it's called but he said his
parents have a lot of expectations
onward and they really try to impose
their goals on you and that's really
what I'm trying to run away from so my
parents want me to be in college but I'm
absolutely miserable in college so you
know in almost like this is a joke at
first but then I feel like in this guy's
voice you can hear some reality you know
I'm I'm looking to run away from home
and
um kind of kind of follow my goals in
life rather than theirs Wow you know
it's interesting I didn't I didn't have
that personally I didn't have that you
know I didn't have anybody really saying
I had a friend of Mines dad that said I
should go to college but other than that
I didn't have that pressure so I can't
imagine what that pressure would be like
and then they feel like you're you're
literally gonna run away from it
so um Wow I'm going to be you're running
away I guess there would be a missing
person kid may have indigestion that's
the thing I can't tell a little bit if
he's being real and he's faking a voice
or if you might have a little bit of
indigestion
could have had a chicken parm gives me
that long word quiet next Monday and all
I really have to my name is 20 bucks and
a greyhound ticket oh man uh uh hold on
just let's keep it well Greyhound I used
to ride Greyhound man a lot of men on
there trying to show you their dick a
lot of people got out of prison some
light cocaine on there I mean hell let's
be some man cut another man's head off
of a Greyhound ball on a Greyhound bus
or could have been Peter Pan lines but I
think they're all coagulated but did
that to him up in upstate New York so
there's a lot of seedy you know a lot of
people you know just riding around
trying to collect [ __ ] abortion money
I feel like on those buses but anyway
onward and really that that doesn't
really worry me because I'm pretty
optimistic about what the future holds
for me okay you're optimistic about what
the future holds
well College can be you know I wish you
could take away the seeing college as
something your parents are pressuring
you into doing and find try to you know
reframe it so it's something that you
can actually enjoy because if you have a
lot of if you feel confident in your
abilities then there should be an
ability you can maneuver or use in a
college on a college template that you
can actually you
no find some joy your own joy onward and
I know I could make something of myself
if I work hard so just letting you know
about my soon to be missing persons
story thank you and big-time scent of
the podcast Wow Wow to think I mean that
guy's going to be a missing person Jesus
man that's crazy I mean I always I
always I love I love missing people man
I've always loved missing people you
know I I just felt I guess I just felt
missing for so long in my life I just
felt missing well look brother if you
were if I mean this was and this call
was six days ago this called with six
days ago so this boy could potentially
be out there and be missing now if
that's the case man I do hope that you
will call and check in it seems to be a
theme this this episode I hope you'll
call in and check in and let us know
what you're doing out there and at least
let your parents know I guess that
you're okay you know I don't know I've
never been a parent but I can only
imagine what it feels like to not be in
touch with your child and that seems
very alarming to me
oh Jesus Christ dude but I don't even
know I don't know what to say man good
luck good luck being you know being
missing and good luck you know I don't
know you know I don't know how you hide
better I know use cash that's what they
say I mean I do encourage you to chase
your dreams I just wish you could figure
out that issue with your parents so that
that didn't have to affect you to the
point where you feel like you had to run
away but maybe that's so intense I just
would be take care yourself $20 in a
greyhound
until advise man I don't know who's
advising you if you're getting it you
know or if you're getting any advice at
all you might want to check in with
somebody that can you know mountain and
check them with some other people
because for me my vote is no on that if
this was you know what's that show where
Howie Mandel and and Melba are on there
I don't know but if this were my vote
I'd say ixnay on the eating on a US Bay
eaving lay on us Bay yeah don't leave on
a bus bro
bad idea Greyhound never a good idea
dude never I'm gonna say that and I've
been known to troll the Greyhound bus
help Twitter feed never a good idea but
anyway I'm going to say I'm going to try
to make a more of an episode that's just
about the missing persons I want to get
into that I want to you know I want to
get in that and I want to answer more of
those calls but but we've just done too
much tonight but I say tonight man I'm
gonna whew some of you guys have a
higher power you don't have to but you
know lift some of these guys up in your
thoughts you know just take a moment and
think about what some of these other
people out in the world are going
through you know we had Stephen in here
tonight and you know he's been through
some pulse she had hold on oh man
got a second one had a woman in it it
seemed like mmm seemed like I had a
little Asian in it that third one but um
but yeah you know keep some of these
guys here thoughts that are going
through some stuff and I appreciate you
guys being here with me you know check
out the album 30 pound bag of hamster
bones and [ __ ] I feel bad even you know
pitch a moan where's at this point but
uh but god bless you guys or or whatever
higher power take care of you and take
care of yourselves man be good to
yourselves
we're not going to go with any outro
music this week
I just had too much to put together man
you know just a lot of moving parts and
and inconscious studios and sure of
helping us put it together over here my
buddy Adam I was texting with earlier
help me come up with some production
ideas and just grateful man a lot of
gratitude from here thank you guys for
supporting podcasts we got to 6000
subscribers on YouTube and that's
awesome man you know and people just
calling leaving cool messages and just
like share this man if you if you think
you know we're trying to put up little
pieces on YouTube of you know people
sharing and and just opening up their
stories and me trying to share my
experiences in return and if you find
one of those resonates with a friend of
yours send it to them and just drop my
text or something you know
because the more that we all share our
[ __ ] dude
you know the cleaner our asses get
that's what I believe the more we share
our [ __ ] the cleaner our asses get take
care of yourself and be good to
yourselves why don't you try that take
care